léonie molle bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat aux élections municipales à la
trinité alors avant de vous demander
pourquoi vous avez décidé de vous
présenter pour ces élections
je vous demande de vous présenter
succinctement donc tout d'abord je
souhaite adresser un bonjour à tous les
auditeurs de martinique 1ère et puis
particulièrement aux trinitéenne et
autres unités mais également aux
habitants du nord atlantique parce que
nous sommes là dans des élections qui
sont à la fois municipales et
communautaires tout à fait voilà et puis
aussi plus largement à tous les
martiniquais qui nous écoutent bien
alors je suis les olim hall et donc je
suis âgé de 62 ans
je suis très n'y tenais à trinité ma vie
se passe à trinité puisque j'y habite
même au niveau professionnel
j'ai exercé pendant 17 ans à trinité
toujours un responsabilités dans le
domaine de l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle puisque j'ai été
directeur d'une agence anpe pendant 12
ans à trinité et que je suis revenu à
premier parcours
ailleurs dans d'autres fonctions en tant
que directeur du centre
afp à de trinité est votre parcours
politique et aussi de citoyens
finalement que quel est il alors mon
parcours politique
il est on va dire naissant puisque je ne
sais je suis nouveau sur l'échiquier
politique est de 7 à travers justement
là la création d'un nouveau mouvement
qui s'appelle nouvel élan trinitéen
alors un mouvement que vous qualifiez de
citoyens vision citoyens c'est un
mouvement citoyen alors sont accros donc
affilié à aucun parti politique au
collège en politique tout à fait
déconnecter les des partis politiques
actuellement donc mais vous avez une
sensibilité je dirais idéologique est ce
que vous êtes plutôt vous placer plutôt
à gauche ou à droite si ça a un sens
pour vous de l'échiquier politique
français et donc martinique bien sûr
alors c'est un mouvement dans lequel on
va rencontrer des personnes de toutes
sensibilités personnellement je suis
plutôt orienté à gauche mais comme il
est convenu avec les camarades de mon
mouvement
ben on ne voit là on ne privilégie pas
cette les sensibilités et donc c'est un
mouvement essentiellement trinité alors
qu'est ce qui a motivé votre candidature
léonie molle à la trinité donc je
d'abord ma candidature se base sur une
observation du fonctionnement de la
ville et j'ai constaté comme d'autres
que cela n'allait pas très bien et qu'il
fallait un sursaut est donc après
l'observation les constats les
diagnostics
je me suis dit qu'il fallait agir et
donc agir pour ça il faut être prêt
j'aurais pu très tôt être candidat mais
j'ai choisi voilà de faire et d'être
prêts pour ça il donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je le suis pour pouvoir
agir avec pas et pour les trinités alors
le nouvel élan trinitéen vous y avez
fait allusion on en a parlé que vous
donc définissez comme un mouvement
citoyen alors c'est vrai que c'est une
tendance qu'on observe de plus en plus
chez nous alors est ce une mode
peut-être n'iront pas ne nous pas jusque
là mais vous quel sens donnez-vous à ce
mot à ce terme citoyens quand vous dites
mouvement citoyen mais voilà alors le
terme citoyens signifie que nous je
place le citoyen au coeur de l'action au
coeur des préoccupations
ça signifie aussi que puisqu'il est
acteur il a à dire il a à faire des
propositions et nous devons en tenir
compte
ça signifie aussi que il faut instaurer
un peu plus de transparence ou que le
citoyen ne découvre pas on va dire par
hasard qui se passe des choses dans sa
ville il doit donc contribuer voilà donc
le sens que je donne aux oies mouvement
citoyen alors vous dites que me voulait
que c'est une liste d'ouverture un peu
qu'ils de rassemblement et d'ailleurs
lors d'un récent article paru dans le
quotidien présentant votre acte de
candidature vous dites vouloir
travailler avec les trinitéens de toute
sensibilité
alors bon c'est bien veut de voeux pieux
peut-être en tout cas une bonne
intention mais ça c'est pas facile à
mettre en oeuvre et ça se traduit ça se
traduit puisque dans mon groupe il y a
des qualités end de tous bords et donc
voilà
et j'insiste avec eux et auprès d'eux
pour que nous restions dans cette
philosophie
et vous pensez que ça peut donner une
action vraiment efficace ça me donnait
une action et qui permet justement là où
je rassemblement alors on arrive déjà
presque au terme de notre entretien
alors qu'elle une fois que vous seriez
arrivée aux affaires municipales les
olim hall quel serait votre premier
dossier et allons-y parce qu'il respire
il tend malheureusement le premier
dossier alors la situation de la ville
et on va dire sensible allez dire pour
ne pas dire préoccupante
il s'agit pour moi et pour mon équipe de
rechercher les accompagnements
financiers faire d'abord un état des
lieux mais pas forcément pour détruire
mais c'est surtout pour rechercher de
nouvelles possibilités d'action ça
signifie qu'il faut voir aussi
rechercher des partenariats financiers
partenariat public privé des
partenariats on va dire avec des
investisseurs nouveau pour faire en
sorte que le centre bourg on retrouve
son attractivité alors septième guide
utiliser un peu par tout le monde mais
là je pense qu'il a tout son sens
s'agissant de trinité qui est une ville
principale du nord atlantique en
quelques mots je crois que vous avez un
oeil attentif aussi sur tartas nous
avait parlé du centre bourg mais alors
je dirais que quelques unités tartane et
les quartiers même combat même
préoccupation
on va alors se connecter en temps c'est
le le centre balnéaire de la ville
maîtrisez également centre-bourg a aussi
des possibilités et les enjeux
concernent l'ensemble du territoire de
trinité donc nous n'allons pas agir de
manière séquencée mais nous allons
avions un peu comme le caterpillar qui
pousse
bien sûr c'est sur cette image que nous
allons nous quitter merci les olim hall
on le rappelle vous êtes candidat aux
élections municipales à à trinité je
vous remercie